sorrel snow guru Lin said you chaired
the Nobel Committee for chemistry and
have just announced another price of
this year which is about the tiny
molecular machines how small only yes
very very small they're so small you
can't see them you can't see them by eye
you can't even see them by a light
microscope so they are on the nanometer
so 1 to 10 nanometer large an anonymizer
if you take a millimeter and divide it
in 1 million parts each part is in
Automator 1 million part for the first
row yeah there were ten one to ten
thousand times smaller than the human
hair yes and you mentioned also that the
dream is always to construct such tiny
machines so how come they overcome huge
challenges
yeah that's a very good question because
I think the dream started in the end of
the 1950s we find - lectures where he
gave a challenge to the scientists
exactly yes to construct molecules that
could act as machines and there are two
obstacles one obstacle is this thing
that you need to have parts that are
freely movable either physically movable
or you need some kind of ISO mais
isomerize able bonds that's one
challenge and the other challenge is
that molecular systems always want to
reach equilibrium and fluctuate around
it and they do have all the random
motions so it's a main challenge to
create motion in one define direction so
when you put in energy you want your
system to either rotate or move in the
direction you have desired they're not
randomly so then yes you want to have
them silent in equilibrium but they also
wanted to stop the movement the Brawn
Brownian movement yeah or at least
overcome it because you can't really
stop it it's there - but you have to
come around it and one way they found to
come over around it was to use assumed
to it molecules so that when you waste
your energy they come in a frustrated or
10 state and when they relax they will
be more prone to relax in one direction
compared to the other because of their
asymmetry and once they have relaxed
they can't get back what does fuel them
how come they move they move because we
give them energy so they are not
autonomous they are moved at will from
their user so we put in a light source
we put in heat or we put in chemical
energy so they are like the man-made
motors you have to put in some kind of
fuel and the jeweller's so mostly they
talked about plants for example they
also live by light successfully putting
the item so is there a dream to
construct living molecules I don't think
that this type of event will eat in
living Molly we've been living me the
something can also replicate itself and
there is nothing in those molecules that
we award today that allowed them to
replicate themselves machines and nano
molecules
there is also a lot of science fiction
about that and then the nano robots are
the main heroes of science fiction
stories and also they pose a threat when
they start to self-replicate themself so
what do you think about those machines
are the big promise or a big threat I
think they're mainly a big promise
because they don't have this property or
self-replication so they cannot really
take over and they are all controlled by
an energy input so if you don't want
them to do something you can just stop
the energy input and they will stop
working and now they are with us here so
what is the next step what what is
really the dream and the vision now I
think one of our Lords put this very
nicely when we call him that this is the
start of a new molecular era so we think
this is a very right time to worry this
Nobel Prize because this is when it
takes off towards the applications and
we can only guess but smart materials
for sure will come material that can
change shape or functional properties
when you for example shine light on them
we mentioned also something that also
Richard Feynman mentioned before it was
about minuscule machines that can bring
the medicines to the body to swallow a
doctor this is also a perspective and
one of our laureates spent for Inga has
done some work in that direction with
antibiotics as a photo switchable so you
can activate it just in the place where
you need the activity
so they have to move and to find the
place and then you can actually activate
them from outside there are three
laureates three different machine types
as IME staff was it the race and the
competition who's coming first I don't
think I think there she came in sequence
so I think siwash was the first one
making the interlocked rings and
developing the synthesis how to make
weave good yield because I think these
kind of molecules could be made before
but the yield was very poor because they
mostly itself when he got most of those
and so you have to play tricks to get
high deal of the interlocked structures
there's really nothing wrong because you
can see it's twice here but it takes two
to tango and the Machine needs more than
one part you can't make a machine of one
part you have to have at least two so
this is that one and he or two dead ones
but together they come alive so you
think a minute in any way or I think I
actually have called cooperated they
seem to be good friends all of them and
they have also worked together on some
projects so they are more much more
co-operators what's going on now the
last machine mentioned in the number
price motivation was
from 1999 so it's almost two decades ago
yes what happened after them a lot of
groups around the world have taken up
this figure is really an exploding
figure in chemistry so that was enormous
enough people say we paste what the
lawyers have done which is a fantastic
achievement I mean means that it's solid
very good solid methods that others can
repeat in other labs and then they have
continued to be on to this and one
development is this materials that as
you change shape when you shine on them
and all three laureates are still active
in the field they are still active yes
yeah thank you Sarah taking your pen
okay thank you very much